a new wave of job cuts could also affect
the outcome of the election this morning
time has run out for some
45 thousand airline workers many of them
are due to be furloughed or laid off
today after talks to extend
government relief programs stalled on
capitol hill
chris van cleave is at reagan national
airport outside washington chris you've
talked with some of those airline
workers
this is a very hard day for them what
are they saying
well good morning as you can imagine
people are waking
up simply devastated take american
airlines the nation's largest carrier
as of today they have 30 percent fewer
employees than they did in january and
next week they're going to drop service
to 15 communities
and that's just one airline
denisha mccluskey became a flight
attendant four years ago
it's a career she loves and thought
she'd have until she retired
but today mccluskey is out of a job
because of the pandemic
i'm really scared about where my health
will lie
without having the proper health care to
you know to continue to live the life
that i've been living
since i've been flying mccluskey reveals
her crohn's disease once nearly killed
her and requires regular costly
infusions
when her health insurance runs out she's
not sure what she'll do
i work so hard to get where i am
and i'm nervous about my health
trickling
being back and forth in the hospital
again with no health care and
it's don't stop i'm sorry
daryl aaron and his wife are both now
furloughed flight attendants
just about a week away from welcoming
their first child
the job i work in requires me to be calm
in the face of
uncertainty my wife is counting on me
for that my daughter's going to be
counting on me for that
and as stressed out as i am i can't let
those emotions overcome me
cbs news estimates around 45 000 airline
workers are subject to furlough or
layoff as soon as today
after the government's 25 billion
payroll support program
expired at least 44 000 other employees
took early exit packages voluntarily
leaving their jobs
and more than 74 000 are taking unpaid
leave
preventing even more job cuts alaska
airlines captain lee erickson and his
wife brenda a flight attendant accepted
early retirement hoping to help save the
jobs of their two kids
both work for the airline i just want to
thank all my co-workers
for the great career that they've given
me but i mostly want to thank you
our passengers who provided me with a
very long very satisfying career
so thank you for the bottom of my heart
the ericsson said it was the right thing
to do but there is
real concern that these job losses will
ripple through the larger economy
commercial aviation supports more than
10 million
u.s jobs outside of the immediate
aviation industry think about
the airport parking business we've
talked to companies there that have laid
off hundreds of employees
in flight magazines they're basically
out of business so those folks
are out of work and even airlines like
southwest and jetblue that have so far
avoided furloughs are warning without
additional aid or
an improvement in demand and look around
there is not a lot of demand
they could see further job cuts as well
now there is one sliver of hope here
both
united and americans say they can
reverse these furloughs
if congress gets a deal in the next few
days
tony we hope so but chris such a good
point each one of those jobs is tied to
other jobs
each job is tied not only to a family
but to a community and then also health
insurance on top of that
so thank you very much very tough
situation there